very funny stand-up nice guy what a
Ronnie Chang wow thank you thank you for
having me thank you for having me Bobby
I've been watching since I was a kid a
real honor to get to know you as a
friend personally and uh uh you've been
always been very supportive supportive
and encouraging to me and I really
appreciate it so uh it's nice to finally
be on your podcast it's an honor to be
on this widely listened um podcast that
uh that you do
um thank you
now can you guys both look at each other
I will a second yeah I don't know this
might be a second I need a second
okay can I get a second yeah can I get a
second yeah because my neck hurts my
throat
my head hurts throat polio right okay
yeah
the last thing I wanted to say is the
last time I saw you
um
um you know a lot of grievances about LA
versus New York and I have to ask you a
question please
um in New York
can you buy a house like this
no in New York you cannot you cannot buy
a house like this unless you're all very
successful no yeah exactly yeah and what
I'm saying to you is is that
one point La zero points New York okay
so what about the traffic the lack of
there's no traffic in New York the fact
that there's no traffic there's nothing
to get a car you can get anyone 20
minutes in New York right you have to
take the [__] Subway yeah and you
know what Subway yeah I've seen the
movie The Warriors oh really
all right all right and I don't want a
guy makeup to beat me up with a bat I've
seen the LA in the movie where what was
it so like Escape L.A
yeah
yeah yeah so that's a post-apocalyptic
that's right they're both apocalyptic
right in a weird way right that was that
was not fair okay go through the food
list alone Korean food better New York
or L.A
100 probably Thai food
probably L.A um Indian food but not
Chinese food Indian food New York I
think Indian food New York yeah I don't
know enough but Indian food in New York
is pretty good I had Chinese food in New
York the best all day all right really
you had Chinese food wow what made you
do that I thought you already Korean
stuff what do you mean I never said that
yeah I never said that the nice thing
about Chinese person say one nice thing
[Laughter]
oh cool
so what else Chinese better martial arts
better martial arts yeah yeah versus
every yeah okay your Martial Arts stars
are like legendary Jet League Jackie
Chan et cetera et cetera Bruce Lee et
cetera Etc Korean Korean entertainment
right now is really going through a boom
that's all I wanted as a little [__]
compliment what the [__] I've given you
nothing
but your problems yeah Koreans have
better zombie movies we have better
zombie movies so
um LA versus New York um yeah also um
you get more stage time yes more stage
time that's a big win yes I saw you in
New York I I was at the cellar back to
back uh and um Bobby went on and uh I've
never seen Bobby uh in New York perform
so I went down I risked death in New
York City D walking leaving my house
risking death yeah to go see Bobby
perform at I just came down to the cell
just no you were on the list oh yeah you
were on before I mean what are you
talking about
it was headlighting you [__] lied no
I forgot or I go what's the list and
they showed me Ronnie was right before I
mean I forgot I genuinely doesn't change
the fact I risked my life no you didn't
live in my life because you had spots I
risked my life to do a spot you're there
every weekend I look at the light no I
risked my life every week okay okay
every week I go and I watched Bobby and
he [__] destroyed it he did too we
both did you know he killed it you
killed it so hot I was like oh my God
this is I've I've only I've only there's
only one or two people who I've ever
been like man I can't follow this well
oh not that I can't fall but I actually
feel nervous to fall you can fall [__]
you talking about I've only been one or
two people where not that I'm that good
I'm just saying that you're amazing what
are you talking about I I just I like
um just in terms of like confidence
levels like there's only been one or two
people who I'm like ah damn this this is
good this would be tough to follow okay
but I had to follow you and that was
hard as well no you [__] destroyed it
it was amazing I was watching this I was
like oh yeah this is why this is why he
has this Garage in L.A because he's able
to kill it so hot but then I'm also like
why doesn't he why why did it take you
so long to perform in New York you know
because I'm never there yeah why because
I don't like you have problems with LA
yeah right you have problems I have a re
I need a reason to be in New York okay
and so when I'm shooting there I go
right right but I'm not going to take a
vacation or go there more stage time in
New York you have to admit more stage
time way more stage time it's almost too
much for me I mean I mean foreign
it's called hustling grinding and
getting better at your craft
so you have a problem with getting
better at you know mastering working
with your mastering your crafts let me
ask you something right yeah yeah are we
very similar in many ways I
am that's what I said same time yeah
we're the same kind of are We I don't
think I think I'm way nicer than he is
reputation roll back the tape yeah roll
back roll back the tape don't worry
30 years